centrale nucléaire de zaporigia est-elle
une bombe à retardement en tout cas
l'état-major ukrainien accuse les Russes
de provocation selon lui Moscou est
placé des engins explosifs sur les toits
si leur détonation ne devrait pas faire
exploser le site le but est de faire
croire à un bombardement ukrainien de la
centrale ça fait très peur très très
peur
tout est possible maintenant ces gens-là
sont des inconscients la Russie n'en
démord pas les Ukrainiens prépareraient
une attaque sur la plus grande centrale
d'Europe depuis Tokyo l'Agence
internationale à l'énergie atomique ne
cache pas son inquiétude yes oui nous
sommes inquiets mais nous sommes
présents on sait comment inviter un
accident
si un réacteur venait à exploser seul un
bassin de 8 km² pourrait le refroidir le
président zellens qui s'est entretenu
hier avec Emmanuel Macron sur ce regain
de tension